To mark the release of Hotel Transylvania
2, let’s take a look at 12 things you probably
didn’t know about the animated monster movie.
Director Genndy Tartakovsky was pretty nervous
about directing comedy legend Mel Brooks,
who voices Dracula’s father, Vlad, because
he grew up loving the comedian’s movies.
Indeed, some of the first movies Tartakovsky
saw after he moved from Russia to America
as a child in the late 1970s were Mel Brooks’
films such as Young Frankenstein and Blazing
Saddles.
And Brooks’ movies certainly came in handy
for the filmmakers, as they used them as reference
material for drawing Vlad’s reactions and
expressions.
As for Mel Brooks, well he drew much of his
inspiration in bringing Vlad to life on screen
from his own grandfather.
For the design of the monster camp, Camp Vamp,
the filmmakers took inspiration from two very
different places, which together gave them
the right look for the kind of dark and private
outdoor place vampires would enjoy.
The first was Yosemite National Park and its
huge rock formations including El Capitán.
And the second was the Norwegian town of Rjukan,
which used to spend half the year cut off
from sunlight because of its location in a
valley.
Until, that is, huge mirrors were placed on
the surrounding mountain to reflect sunlight
into the town square.
When the character designers first created
Mavis and Johnny’s son, Dennis, they drew
him with a big mane of red hair, like his
father.
But when they turned that design into a computer
animation, they found Dennis’ hair looked
too big for his head to hold!
In fact, Dennis’ hair took up so much room
that Mavis or Johnny would have needed arms
twice the length in order to pick him up;
and, on top of that, his mass of curls kept
the light from reaching his face.
So, the animators gave Dennis a haircut!
Six-year-old Asher Blinkoff, who is the voice
of Dracula’s grandson Dennis, isn’t the
only member of his family to appear in Hotel
Transylvania 2.
Asher’s older sister, Meira, not only voiced
one of the werewolf puppies in the first movie,
but she’s also doing some additional voices
in the sequel including vampire kids.
Asher was especially excited to get the role
as Dennis because whenever he or his sister
gets a part, it’s a family tradition to
go out for a sushi dinner!
Also, according to Asher’s mum, one of the
highlights for her son of working on Hotel
Transylvania 2 was riding in a golf cart around
the Sony Pictures studio lot!
Dracula’s daughter, Mavis, was designed
by French artist Anette Marnat, who’s based
in Paris.
The filmmakers never actually met Anette in
real life, but thanks to her blog they discovered
her work when they were searching for character
designers for the first Hotel Transylvania.
The Hotel Transylvania movies are a bit of
a family affair for Adam Sandler, who voices
Dracula.
On the first movie, his real-life wife Jackie
provided the voice of his on-screen wife Martha,
and his daughters Sunny and Sadie also lent
their voices to the film, with Sadie voicing
young Mavis and one of the werewolf pups,
Winnie.
And Sunny and Sadie have returned for Hotel
Transylvania 2.
Sadie is back as werewolf Winnie, while this
time Sunny is the voice of Baby Dennis, as
well as one of the vampire kids.
When Character Designer Carter Goodrich was
looking for inspiration for the design of
Griffin the Invisible Man, who’s voiced
by actor David Spade, he didn’t have to
look any further than his own nose, as Griffin’s
glasses are based on the ones Goodrich wears
himself!
The hairstyle of Frankenstein’s wife, Eunice,
is based on a Brillo pad!
And Eunice’s hair isn’t the only rough
thing about the character.
According to Fran Drescher, who voices Eunice,
during her recording sessions the filmmakers
kept encouraging her to make Eunice sound
gruffer, more obnoxious, and annoying!
Barcelona-based designer Carlos Grangel, who
contributed to the look of many of the movie’s
characters including Murray the Mummy, hates
designing on white paper.
So, instead, he drew all his monster designs
on the inside of cereal boxes, which he prefers
to blank paper because it has more of colour
and texture to it, which helps him get creative!
In fact, Grangel asks fellow artists at his
studio in Spain to bring in their old cereal
boxes for him to draw on.
Andy Samberg, who voices Dracula’s son-in-law
Jonathan, has said he based his character
on himself in high school "and on a lot of
guys he knew in the Bay Area in California."
Jonathan loves seeing the world and is super-positive
when faced with adversity.
When Sony was designing characters for Hotel
Transylvania, they had to be careful about
copyright issues.
Although characters such as Dracula and Frankenstein’s
monster are in the public domain, Universal
created specific designs for those characters
in their popular horror movies of the 1930s
onwards.
So, Sony had to avoid certain specific features
associated with Universal’s classic monsters.
For example, Frankenstein could not have green
skin or bolts in his neck, and Dracula could
not have a sharp widow’s peak or a cape
with a red lining.
Also, instead of calling Frankenstein’s
mate the Bride of Frankenstein, they called
her Eunice, and on top of that, she could
not have two white lightning bolts in her
hair, so in Hotel Transylvania, she has just
one streak instead.
Now, let me know in the comments below, who’s
your favourite character in the Hotel Transylvania
movies and why?
And what would you like to see in the planned
Hotel Transylvania TV series?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!